your Prime Minister as it happens my
Prime Minister as well
Trudeau made a campaign pledge to keep
Canada's fiscal deficit and no more than
25 billion dollars a pledge already
broken as it happens by your first
budget what message we're here in New
York City what message does that send to
investors particularly foreign investors
whom you need to buy Government of
Canada bonds well I think you know the
message we want foreign investors to
have which is the same invest the same
message we want Canadians to have is
that we are focused on growth we're
focused on growth that's gonna help
Canadians so clearly where our agenda is
to help middle class Canadians to
succeed after a challenging era but
importantly we want to help them in the
next generation so we've made a
commitment to growing the economy it's
something that we know will make a
difference for the next generation and
for investors we know that they want to
see an economy that's going to grow at a
healthy pace over the long term and
that's exactly what we're setting out to
do we're talking about Canada here
though Canada is the country that taught
the english-speaking world how to be
fiscally responsible how to run balanced
budgets and standard in Poor's and
Moody's rewarded Canada by restoring its
triple-a credit rating what if they
don't agree with the pro-growth as well
well I think they're going to agree
because what what we've said we're going
to do is be prudent along the way so we
are blessed in Canada with a
particularly good situation we've been
able to make decisions over time that
have lowered our net debt to GDP so so
Canada among the g7 countries has the
lowest net debt to GDP which gives us
the most capacity to make investments to
grow the economy so so Canadians told us
they wanted us to invest to grow the
economy but importantly the IMF the OECD
and when I sit around the table with g20
countries they're recognizing that in an
era of low growth in an era of
demographic change what we should be
doing is making investments using fiscal
measures in order to really grow the
economy so so we are getting we are
getting Canadians on board we are
getting international observers on board
and I'm confident that investors
investors in Canadian bonds
are going to be supportive because we're
gonna enhance the long-term trajectory
of our country you're not afraid of the
bond vigilantes we're we're in fact
embracing all people who look towards
how can how can Canada be more
successful in the future and and we we
know that having not only a better
infrastructure which helps people in the
country but also goods and services to
get to market creating more innovative
environment and and and creating an edit
plan for for growing businesses this is
going to really help Canadians and it's
it's gonna it's going to put us on a
world stage as they as a country that's
taking the decisions it can really make
a difference well let's talk about that
world stage and the commitment to
investment the developed world as we
know is stuck in a slow growth gear
interest rates are at or near the zero
bound and there's some questions about
the efficacy of unorthodox monetary
policy is it safe to say based looking
at this budget that you that you and
your government believe that spending is
the only way to kick-start an economy
like Canada's at this point well let me
step back and say first of all we don't
call it spending what we're doing is
we're making investments in in the
future of our country so so there are
there are places where those investments
might look like spending but investing
in education for indigenous people this
is something is going to help more
people in our workforce over the longer
term we would say that yes we need to be
doing things that are gonna that are
going to enhance our growth fiscal
measures are really a prescription for
what we should be doing given given the
Canadian situation the low interest
rates you mentioned our capacity to make
investments and our ability with a very
educated workforce to take advantage of
a more innovative society is a positive
thing for us would it help Canada's
growth trajectory and for that matter
the rest of the developed and developing
world if other countries like the United
States for example or the UK we're not
so fiscally conservative well we
recognize that every country is in a
different situation sure again our
capacity is is very positive because of
where we are in terms what I'm trying to
say is would you like to see them doing
what you're doing we do believe
that taking fiscal measures is
appropriate in in the face of a
low-growth environment and that's
something that we'll be talking about at
the g20 taking the decisions that
governments can take in order to enhance
the the productive capacity of their
country and but also to help the next
generation of in our case Canadians to
be more successful and obviously that's
a discussion and each country will have
a different situation in terms of how
they can execute on that mr. Minister
your budget adds four and a half billion
dollars in new child subsidies
introduces means-testing is income
redistribution the only way to really
truly address the inequality problem
well from our point of view we look back
over the last generation and realized
that middle-class Canadians have not
been as successful as they might have
hoped based on the growth in our economy
so that's just a fact that we want to
deal with we believe that finding ways
to enhance their ability to spend on
their family is not only gonna help them
which is very important but also gonna
actually help our economy so so someone
who's a middle-income Canadian getting
in our case you know an average twenty
three hundred dollars more in child
benefits for the nine out of ten
families that benefit from the way we've
done this they're gonna put that money
back in the economy so so good for them
good for the economy and over time that
will help our growth so so we think that
it's it's about helping people yes and
helping the next generation by having a
more productive and more successful
economy philosophically do you agree
with the point on inequality that that's
how it should be done
well philosophically we agree that
having a country that enables all people
to be successful is important so if we
have a country where the middle class
isn't able to grow their incomes then
that's not okay because we're able to
grow our economy we need to make sure
that it's inclusive growth and that's
what we're working towards one
conspicuous absence in the budget is
money for Bombardier hmm why well in our
budget what we've done is we've we've
taken a look at how we can deal with the
economy broadly that includes thinking
about our an innovation agenda which
we're going to spend more time on over
the course of this year in the case of
one of our sectors the aerospace sector
it's a critically important industry to
us we've been very successful
Lombardi has been a very successful
company in that their new jet series is
the C series I want to say to anybody
out there considering buying it is a
great jet what we're doing right now is
we're doing some due diligence on a
request that memoria is put forward
around government coming along with them
in that C series and we've not finished
that due diligence yet you came out of
business mr. Minister so you understand
the issues that concern investors and
for that matter taxpayers would you
attach conditionality to financing or
funding from Bambara J that would
require the demolition let's say of the
dual class share structure because
otherwise you know what taxpayers are
going to think they're gonna say the
Canadian the Canadian government is
subsidizing a very wealthy family that
has a controlling interest in that
company I think I think Canadians expect
us to do our due diligence around the
proposition that's been put before us to
consider different alternatives and how
we can make investments so that needs to
consider how we can ensure that we have
employment in the country in the
aerospace sector it needs to consider
how we can ensure that we continue to be
successful including Bombardier so we're
going to consider all of those those
issues as we go through our due
diligence and it's really preliminary
for me to talk about any specific
decisions that we might get to it very
quickly because we do have to run how
long until that due diligence is done
you know we don't have an exact timeline
on that so I know you'd like a deadline
but we think in order to do our work
properly we need to we need to work
through and understand the issues and
we're doing that and when we have
results we'll come back to Canadians